[Music]
uh I
'll let you know about today's election.
Our damage is minor and there is no casualty. Due to
humane and advanced drone combat, there are no cases of us in our country today.
Why are drones so powerful?
4 a wh of 6 reporters
Why are you every night with that woman?
If there's no choice but to fight and die or give up and die, then we'll fight until we die and survive
That's why we fight and we're proud of it
Put it on,
can you understand that you have no choice but to die
Darts ana
ni
me
Ah ah ah
Do you think we're fighting for what we want?
Yeah, I just wanted to make sure
.
nd directly
dan We can finally follow the path we wanted to go to where we wanted to go.
can you please